hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning now it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
ah ha ha I'm just checking in on you
I am just checking in on you see now
your weeks going how's your week going
oh yeah really
oh god bless you God bless you God love
you
God [ __ ] love you I'm having a great
week
we just today we did the table read for
episode 10 the final episode of season 4
but that's it it [ __ ] killed and I
think that we got coming together this
is going to look like it's an even
better season than last season amazing
writers room this year so I mean how
every year of course but this year went
to another level so thank you to
everybody helping out and all of a
sudden the clouds are starting to pot
and old freckles I'm gonna have time to
arroba sighs you know I docked out the
all things comedy we're doing so we're
doing some business with the Comedy
Central made some stand-up specials and
then we have a sort of a premium blend
type show that we been recording the
last two days shooting it I should say
and then tonight's the last night where
the [ __ ] is that it I always forget the
name of that damn theater let me see
here it's on 7th Ave Theater 7th Ave Los
Angeles Los Angeles I did a stand-up
show there before the tarragon or
something like that is that what it's
called
you [ __ ] [ __ ] bill why the hell
tarragon theater that's it the tarragon
theater is that it no that's not it hang
on a second
the teragrams ballroom that's where the
show is that tonight and I'll be doing
like like a half hour after all the
young bucks go up there and they do
their thing I'm gonna close out the show
with a half-hour stuff most of it new
[ __ ] since my last taping on my special
so look at me I got the special behind
me I got the this taping behind me I got
the [ __ ] my spike efforts for
families kind of getting behind me I'm
AI got to edit it for them you know help
edit it for the next I don't know how
many months but uh yeah
it's all good so I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm gonna do with myself maybe get
caught up on my reading speaking of
getting caught up how about your boys
last night how'd you like that well if
you didn't you're from Montreal or
Toronto everybody else that's what I
love about being a Bruins fan is around
the league people love us I've never
seen a team win less cups and have more
hatred around the league you know what I
mean you'd think we were actually
successful as though we've won one Cup
since 1972 once you guys relax all right
you [ __ ] boo is there anything worse
than listen to somebody complaining
about you know physical play some of
these [ __ ] Toronto fans I mean I know
Bruins fans probably just as bad of
course I don't look at that [ __ ] you
know they lose game two and all of a
sudden that they're putting out pictures
of like the refs wearing Bruins jerseys
it's like what were they wearing Toronto
jerseys in the first [ __ ] game you
[ __ ] if we lose the ribs cheated no
is another heart-stopping game or we I
forget what the [ __ ] we were up we went
up like five three years I thought the
game was [ __ ] over and then all of a
sudden they they closed it to like I
don't know four to three or something
like that that my my daughter came down
I missed a little bit of it I've just
been catching it and patch is uh like
patches of it even though I'm
emotionally all in because everybody in
the house laughed at me when the Bruins
scored how about Marshawn sticking with
that pass huh
I mean oh I think he gave it to PI there
was the posture knock
first pass once the defenseman skates a
nice play and it went right back on his
stick and they gave my day all right
their [ __ ] friend loved it and the
shocker of all shockers Tampa Bay losing
four straight give it up for your
Columbus Blue Jackets tell you right now
they're gonna have a long layoff and the
big thing they got to worry about is a
letdown I mean they gotta be flying high
after beating this team but last time I
checked you got to win 16 games before
your hosts hoist Lord Stanley over your
head I'm an old white guy and I'm
talking in clean [ __ ] cliches came to
say what I'm trying to say I wonder how
long you could filibuster as a sports
announcer just saying all that cliched
stuff everybody ain't going out there
they played like a team everybody was
involved I'll tell you when you get all
lines fire and good things are gonna
happen they went to the net and I'll
tell you that's where the goals are okay
you can't be out there on the perimeter
nobody's ever scored from behind the
goal except for Wayne Gretzky and you're
not Wayne Gretzky so I'll tell you right
now you got to get your [ __ ] Canadian
ass Russian ass or whatever the [ __ ] you
are right for that goddamn neck because
that's where the goals are these goddamn
catch say they're on the wrong side of
the puck they're trying to get on
Instagram make a [ __ ] degree a
difficulty this isn't high dive we're
not high diving here we're playing
hockey if I see one more [ __ ] mascot
one of these goddamn Marines I'm gonna
throw a kid down on the ice
Marc Oh getting a lot of your anger out
and I watched a little bit of NBA
basketball I watched some of the the
Boston Celtics and you know great game
there we [ __ ] won that game but I'd
be honest with you dude like I don't
even know what the [ __ ] goes on in the
NBA anymore I try to watch it but uh I
have a theory on what happened to the
NBA all right sit down for this one if
you want to hear somebody who's picked
last in gym class tell you what tell you
what's wrong with the NBA all right I'm
going big on this one I'm gonna say it
all right Michael Jordan the greatest
basketball player of all time was also
one of the worst things that ever
happened to NBA hoop okay the same way
Eddie Van Halen
in 1978 with van halen one was one of
the worst things that ever happened to
guitar playing in the 1980s alright and
basically why I'm saying is when you
have somebody of their level of talent
just an absolute genius they are so far
beyond everybody else that when mere
mortals interpret what they do they get
it wrong because they are limited by the
talent that they were blessed with so
with Eddie Van Halen I know I've used
him as a reference before so many people
that came after him what they looked at
Eddie and they were just like take
guitar solo plays many notes as you can
within whatever the four bars that you
have and then it just became noise the
whole [ __ ] it's some of these [ __ ]
guitar solos for me I know these guys
could play but like you know it's just
like it's almost like you ever get
cornered in a party by some [ __ ]
cokehead and there's no back and forth
there's no conversation that just
[ __ ] punishing you yeah that's what a
lot of those SOLAS were all right and
before Michael Jordan came along you had
to have a big man to win you had to feed
your big man and blah blah blah and all
that [ __ ] and he came in with such a
talent he said not only do I not need a
big man I'm gonna jump over your big man
and you [ __ ] power forward and I'm
gonna so dominate this game that the
rest of my teammates are their nicknames
gonna be my supporting cast now I know
when he started you know passing the
ball and everything that's when he
started to beat the Pistons I'm not
saying he was just totally doing it
himself but like all these people that
came after him grew up they wanted to be
like Mike and then not Mike but they're
still playing that way so everybody
tried to [ __ ] win and it didn't work
so the fallout of that I believe was
then the pylon championship team because
Michael set the bar at six championships
in the modern era if you wanted to beat
Mike or be as good as him you had to win
six and people just weren't good enough
to [ __ ] do it so they just had the
pylon teams and it started with Kobe and
Shaq with the Lakers
and then you had the big three in Boston
and then the Miami [ __ ] Heat and now
you got the the Golden State Warriors
and if you watch it I swear to and this
this whole fall out of that is you now
have the person that's taking it beyond
Jordan where it's like not only do I not
need my other teammates I don't even
like being coached so you have somebody
out there you know people always octo
T's got like 21 points in the first half
it's like dude the only [ __ ] number
that matters is the score went down by
three I don't give a [ __ ] East East this
person is I just see these guys they
turn their team into this
one-dimensional and attack it's like
this guy's gonna try to [ __ ] beat the
entire [ __ ] team and somehow if you
play team basketball like the San
Antonio Spurs nobody pays attention and
I saw this thing on Instagram showing
all these big stars that have since
retired and they go who do you miss the
most and of course everybody's picking
Kobe I mean he's probably I don't know
I would he's got to be at least the top
two one-on-one [ __ ] players of all
time absolute beast
and then he combined that with his
wanting to win and all of that [ __ ]
however sitting right in the middle and
nobody talking about him was [ __ ] Tim
Duncan and I might just be an old
[ __ ] [ __ ] here but what I liked
about Tim Duncan is Tim Duncan could win
with anybody where I felt like Kobe
could win but he needed everybody he
needed like a zillion [ __ ] free
agents every [ __ ] year it seemed they
would just every three years they would
clean house and he would get a fresh
batch of some of the best people in the
NBA to play with
I don't know so when I watched the
[ __ ] game now I I'll tell you when
you got a player his caliber you know
he's going to have to get his touches
it's like dude [ __ ] he's touches I was
watching the game last night okay and
what's-his-face
Reggie Miller we go into the fourth
quarter I think we were up by like two
points he goes you know for the you know
the rest of this game's gonna be all
Kyrie now maybe he was saying passing
the ball or whatever to but I don't know
I just hear that all the time and I do
makes me feel so old I'm I sit that
yellow into TV like you didn't play that
kind of ball even when you were [ __ ]
destroy in the Knicks you still knew you
had to play team ball I don't fight or
not whatever okay I'm done with my old
man rant alright but I think that that's
that is basically you like I said I'm
done and I'm still gonna go here I think
that that's what's happened with
basketball and for an old guy like me
that's why I don't get it when I'm
watching I'm like oh my god
dead down by ten and that guy came down
the court didn't pass it and just
launched a three and threw up a [ __ ]
brick they're gonna call it timeout and
put them on the bench and they don't
it's just how it's played now so but
what I will say there are things that
are way better okay before I'm that
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know giving you the
global warming speech about professional
sports in no time in basketball have
there ever been this many people over
this the height of six foot ten that can
hit a [ __ ] three-pointer like a guard
I mean it's it's [ __ ] unbelievable so
there are whatever there are there are
better things I will tell you though NHL
has changed a lot since I was a kid and
I actually I like I mean I missed the
fights
I do miss two line passes and that type
of thing but it's it's a [ __ ] great
game it's still you can't have one guy
go out and try to just take over the
entire [ __ ] game by the way how about
a vet skin' knocking out that [ __ ]
nineteen year old that's such a weird
thing he's 33
he outweighed the kid by [ __ ] forty
pounds the kid asked him to fight what's
he supposed to do Jesus Christ he gave
me old to peace there I felt bad for
that kid but I also respect him having
the balls you know 19 years old you're
playing in the NHL and you take on a 33
year old Russian I mean you got balls I
got to give him that I don't even know
what that series is at right now
but hang on a second Washington Post why
the [ __ ] does it say that since when the
hell do I look at that maybe I looked at
an article Washington Capitals
all right now what why would I want to
go to Wikipedia why is that my default
[ __ ] thing every time don't enough
people don't enough people go to your
goddamn site that you got a [ __ ]
direct me right there
alright Washington Capitals the series
is two games to one now it is [ __ ]
wide open wide [ __ ] open now the
Tampa Bay is is out of it this era bet
everybody's eyes [ __ ] lit up what a
story that would be if the [ __ ]
Columbus Blue Jackets
end up winning the East can you imagine
that I'm actually enjoying watching them
winning just a seat [ __ ] totally
smiling I've never seen that guy smile
so much of my life when they went up two
games to none he was like that smile on
his face the way he was holding his
hands together he looked like he was
watching his first-born take their first
few steps and as a recovering angry
lunatic it's fun to see an angry guy
like that showed just pure joy I feel
like in his head it he felt like finally
I drew up a game plan that my team heard
and they completely [ __ ] executed it
to a tee and it [ __ ] worked I mean
that's got it's got to be Nirvana
forever for a coach so that was
definitely definitely fun to watch but I
apologize to all the young people listen
to this me bitching about the game but
those are just my theories and as you
get older the more theories you have
because it keeps that voice out ahead
that's like you're gonna die soon keep
that out of your [ __ ] head
anyways how many minutes have I done
here how many new minutes it's a time
for the read already [ __ ] penguins
lose four straight now is that guy in
the front office
Josh Adam Meyers who's taping is set
tonight from the goddamn Comedy Jam and
the 500 podcast he's uh he was telling
me that the Capitals last year didn't
pay their front office guy that GM then
all he did was just lead them you know
put together a team that led them to
their first Stanley Cup in the history
of the team and they don't pay him they
went to
Theo Epstein dare I say remember that
Theo Epstein ended a [ __ ] 86 year
curse and they started [ __ ] with his
money he's like I'm out of here then and
then they paid him then a few years
later he was gone that guy he's got to
be the greatest foreign office guy ever
the guy ended almost two combined two
hundred years of curses and we wouldn't
pay him speaking of which how about you
Boston Red Sox my gut all I've been
hearing is the stories I haven't had
time to watch Yankees are kicking our
ass and they're in [ __ ] last place a
little bit of a hangover from the World
Series party once again it goes to
Wikipedia like I don't know what the
Boston Red Sox are all right I know what
they are they're a [ __ ] last-place
team right now we lose 5 to 3 from the
new from your New York Yankees and now
that game I believe we're 6 and 13 I
wonder you know how many [ __ ]
[ __ ] at new Yankee Stadium were too
busy under the stadium eating prime rib
I just have to say as a [ __ ] baseball
fan
that [ __ ] Roman feast that they have
for everybody down behind home plate
it's just it's the [ __ ] worst you're
the New York Yankees you have the most
[ __ ] World Series titles give the
most titles of anybody in the four major
sports and we're out where are you
[ __ ] feds down there talking a
[ __ ] Rachael Ray whoever [ __ ]
celebrity chef is down there cooking for
him [ __ ] watching the game to stay
home stay home you [ __ ]
I actually got those seats one time I
went to a game but I mean at least 10
[ __ ] years ago I forget how long ago
that state has been around but it feels
like it was like 10 years ago maybe
eight years ago and I sat down there I
just loaded up got my food and got the
[ __ ] out there and I watched the game
and it was ridiculous like the Yankees
of course probably were in first place
and to sit there you felt like they were
like you know already mathematically
eliminated I don't know that's a sad
thing and they say oh you know that's
how it is it's like no it's just greed
it's greed by the [ __ ] owners where
that capitalism thing well you can't
just be a [ __ ] billionaire you got to
be a multi billionaire and to the
detriment I don't begrudge anybody god
knows on my tax rant I don't progress as
long as you pay your [ __ ] taxes but
grudge anybody making any more money but
when it's detrimental to your product
I'll tell you right now that's when you
gotta take a step back and you know try
to figure out what matters I don't know
I gotta I gotta [ __ ] uh I guess sit
down and watch the game I have had a
ridiculous urge now that I have a little
bit of time off here I mean I'm going to
Iceland doing this toilet goes from
Iceland to Israel but I really have I
have a couple few weeks off in May
before it starts to get crazy again and
I would love to go to a [ __ ] Dodgers
game I think like an old man you know
and [ __ ] keep score and have myself a
[ __ ] hot dog I only wish there was a
smoking section if I could just sit
there and smoke cigars god damn it and
hang with one of my cigar buddies like
Bert Kreischer you know Bert's always
down to [ __ ] smokers dick Josh Adam
Meyers you know be a hell of a thing or
Mike binder who actually directed my
latest special coming out and when you
guys see how [ __ ] beautiful this
thing is you might actually forget the
shitty material you're listening to and
that's what we're going for all right
let's do the advertising here butcher
blocks everybody Oh before I forget I
get to tell you the latest cutest thing
that my daughter did all right
the love of my life the apple of my eye
I woke her up right I didn't wake her up
she was up I come and she's silly as
hell and she's so smart and just keeps
getting more and more beautiful and I
know I'm bragging as a dad but I'm
telling you right now it's a
good-looking kid so I get her up and I'm
getting her changed and everything so I
said hey I go you
pancakes for breakfast she goes yeah I
go alright I go or do you want a
smoothie she looks at me and she goes
pancakes and smoothie that's the first
time she's used and she knows to link it
or smoothie as she says I just gave her
the pancakes the healthy ones too
that I've been making here all right
butcher bucks everybody here we go oh I
love these guys oh do I love these guys
you know something I'm gonna be cooking
up some of their heritage bread pork
tomorrow I got this this recipe I'm
trying one of those [ __ ] you know
when you're in in line at the grocery
store and they have like a little
magazine that has like just a bunch of
recipes so this whole issue was
dedicated to just make it an entire meal
and like a skillet you know and they
have this great recipe for for a pork
chop dinner you know you see her and on
both sides up top and then you finish it
in the oven with a heat thermometer this
you don't overcook it dry it out the
[ __ ] thing worst thing ever it's
really involved and there's a couple of
reducing zuv liquids and putting pork
chops in an na na in an aluminum tent
this is [ __ ] involved and I'm giving
myself permission to only do an okay job
the first time but I'm gonna get this
this meal down and this is gonna be one
of these meals that when I have people
over when I'm entertaining okay when I'm
wearing one of my evening gowns this is
this is the meal that I'm gonna pull out
to [ __ ] impress people
of course I'll make it so yeah um we i'm
sorry we're vegan now it looks delicious
if you're into murdered pigs alright put
your box everybody butcher box delivers
healthy 100% grass-fed and
grass-finished beef free-range organic
chicken and heritage breed pork the
incredible quality of butcher box meats
starts with the commitment to raising
animals humanely and free of antibiotics
and hormones before they're slaughtered
each box comes with at least eight to 11
pounds of meat which is enough for 24
individual size meals or if you're a
[ __ ] at a Yankee game that ought to get
you to the third inning you can choose
from five different box types all beef
beef and chicken beef and pork mix box
custom box let you choose it let you
choose your own cuts telling you right
now I don't give a [ __ ] if you're a
[ __ ] bulimic vegetarian you owe it to
yourself the heritage breed pork man I'm
telling you it's unbelievable ok the
butcher box difference butcher box meats
come from the humanely raised open
pasture animals that are never fed
antibiotics hormones or fatty fillers
get the ultimate breakfast bundle that's
two packages of bacon and two pounds of
breakfast sausage for free in your first
box plus $20 off your first box go to
butcher box comp / / or enter the promo
code BRR this is great if he got kids
this is also good to know that they're
not gonna be you know your son won't be
able to grow a mustache by the time he's
7 you know keep the hormones out keep
them [ __ ] out of here all right one
more read here HELOCs helix there's
nobody on the planet like you you're
special everybody needs to hear what you
think on social media so why would you
buy a generic mattress built for
everyone else
next please mention all the talking
points below well if you [ __ ] wrote
it I'm gonna read it how long we've been
in business alright hellix leap built a
sleep quiz that takes two minutes to
complete and they use the answers to
match your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
whether you're a side sleeper a hot
sleeper like a plush or firm bed Oh
behave with helix hellix there's no more
guessing or compromising just go to
helix sleep calm / burn take their two
minutes sleep quiz and they'll match you
to a mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life four couples
helix helix can even split the mattress
down the middle providing individual
support needs and feel preferences for
each side let me ask you this when you
[ __ ] which side are you on
I think that depends on who
on the bottom um doggystyle would be
confusing both my knees are on the
mattress so are mine and my hands okay
fair enough honey your side of the bed
all right helix sleep was even aware
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2019 by GQ and Wired
magazine and CNN called it the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on they have a 10-year warranty and you
can get to try out you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk-free right now
HELOCs helix is offering up to $125 off
their mattress orders for our listeners
get up to $125 off a HELOCs helix sleep
calm wait at helix sleep calm / / that's
HELOCs sleep calm / / for $125 off your
mattress order helix sleep calm / /
that's h e li
/ oh yeah I was I was telling furs Imai
by the way Paul virzi he's down in
Raleigh North Carolina at the improv
this weekend and catch him now before he
goes to the theaters I'm telling you I'm
telling you I saw it I saw that that set
and got them he's been absolutely
murdering but I'll tell you it's hard
when you're a half Greek half Sicilian
New Yorker to go down to Raleigh the
first time in headline and sell some
tickets go down there and say that you
were there for the first his first
headlining gig down there last I talked
to him I think he was doing a bunch of
radio down there so I bet a lot of you
know that he's he's in town but I was
talking to him on the phone about that
whole theory that I had on like
basketball because he was laughing you
know he always laughs at me cuz you know
he's like the [ __ ] he's a kid to me
you know wearing the Jordans and all
that [ __ ] and I'm this [ __ ] old man
wearing a [ __ ] Irish sweater oh I
hate how true that is and I was saying
like dude I swear to God they treat the
stars in this in the NBA they treat him
like hot chicks you know I guess they
kind of do that in all leagues but I
don't know I have no idea bill please
don't go back to
stupid theories about a game you were
never really that good at you know what
fair enough fair enough here's my
impression of a [ __ ] Laker fan oh
yeah if Kobe's that bad how come he also
won an Oscar why does he have a [ __ ]
Boston accent bill let me do that again
oh my god if like Kobe's that bad like
you know how many Oscars did Bill
Russell win Golden Globe much is it half
time yet I want to get some Botox I'm
sorry sorry LA I love it out here what
am i doing all right is that the podcast
no I still got another three minutes
so anyways tonight and we be down at
that [ __ ] Theatre the ballroom there
the tarragon ballroom someone it's
called I got to look up ballroom is
tarragon like a food I don't know no
that's tilapia that's a fish the [ __ ] is
tarragon the teragrams his tarragon a
spiced tarragon spice that is all right
okay I thought I was going [ __ ] crazy
oh I bet a lot of tarragon it's been
putting in bags a weed before huh I
wonder what it's good for tarragon is so
good if you have tingling in your ass
just rub a little bit alright tarragon
is ace is a spices of perennial herb in
the sunflower family I knew I didn't
like him it's a redhead you don't like
anything about the Sun it is widespread
in the wild across much of Eurasia and
North America what is Eurasia is that
Europe infused Asia and his cult is at
the Middle East and is cultivated for
culinary and medical purposes you know
the amount of people if you'd ask him
what continent the Middle East is it
they would not guess Asia no they would
not and in Turkey I believe is half in
Europe half in Asia
I don't know Bill but we're all half
listening at this point okay you're
gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] on the end
and then give of what a geography lesson
via a spice nobody gives a [ __ ] about
alright fair enough fair enough
alright listen god bless all you have a
wonderful weekend let's go Bruins
let's go Celtics Red Sox it's not too
late to turn it around
I'm sure ESPN is already having the sky
fold is it is it too early to make a
move there's still snow on top of the
Green Monster anyways there's gonna be a
little break here enjoy some music and
then there gonna be another half hour
bonus material of a Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcasts from Thursday earlier this year
are from seven years ago whenever the
[ __ ] I started doing this sorry if this
podcast was a little bit off I was icing
my calves the entire time one of the
things I swear to God I didn't realize
how [ __ ] up my goddamn body is I'm
still undoing 40 years I was like I'm 50
yeah 40 years god I feel like the first
ten years it's like a brand new car and
you can run around do whatever somewhere
in like my teens I had my first throw
out my back and I'm finally [ __ ]
getting this [ __ ] worked out but uh
Jesus Christ dude I swear to God my
calves the lady she went to put her
[ __ ] elbow in it I felt like I
literally had like a softball sized like
ball of Hornets in each of my caps like
I was like popping up off the table I
she had to take like this candle thing
she like like I don't know what the [ __ ]
it is like she liked it it heats it up
and she has to hold it like a half inch
away from the skin to like melt up melt
all of the [ __ ] gristle I've had from
years and years of just you know nobody
stretched in the 80s she just worked out
I used to bench do all the dumb eighties
[ __ ] right and that's how I [ __ ] up my
shoulders and then I would get on a bike
and I would ride it for like 15 miles
every single day 18 on Saturday and then
I would take a day off
on Sunday were you shredded bill yes I
was I was shredded and but I never
stretched and now I'm paying the price
for it now I look like a [ __ ] bald
freckled mr. Magoo limping around my
house I literally sit down for like ten
minutes watching TV and when I stand up
I feel like I've been you know that
feeling you have when you've been asleep
for eight hours for all you other old
people out there of people beginning to
feel old I've said this before in the
podcast and goddamn and I'm gonna say it
again before you get out of bed in the
morning all right take your toes and
point it back at your knees if you
immediately feel a charley horse just
point your feet in the opposite
direction it'll release and you'll be
all right but pointing at your knees if
you can
I'm doing it right now oh that's great
right you just leave it there for like
you know a good thirty seconds then go
in the other direction pointing the
other way you get a charley horse that
way same thing just bring your feet back
up and it'll go away hopefully but I'm
not a professional so don't hold me
accountable here and then once you've
done those two stretches move your feet
clockwise and then counterclockwise and
and then get up don't get up because
what [ __ ] you up is that first step
that first step of the day when you
haven't stretched and what a way to
start you know you know what you know
when you get out of bed you just take
that first definitely you wake up your
wife or husband or whatever you don't
want to do that [ __ ] all right that's it
this is a very old podcast you know if I
keep podcasting like this complaining
about sports leagues and my physical
ailments I think my next big advertisers
going to be like Jarret ah do they still
make that [ __ ] they used to always have
that on the Lawrence Welk Show he would
do like these ads for Geritol Geritol is
that how you spell it
Geritol liquids it still exists what is
it for now the one time I want I want
[ __ ] Wikipedia to help me out I think
it's it's spying on me all right well
we're making him mad let it go to Google
wiki Geritol
is united
it's trademark name for various dietary
supplements past and present Oh see that
what they did was they change with the
time I see remember that I'm gonna wants
well goodnight sleep tight and pleasant
dreams to you was the whitest show ever
there's a wish and a prayer for every
dream become true I swear to god this is
legal in the song end of the show and
now till we meet again
adios all of wow this is them like in a
very like passive-aggressive way like
shouting out all the people that we had
oppressed avi does a night we had the
New Mexicans in there the French and the
[ __ ] the Germans right there what did
we do a little French French and Indian
War right there I don't know but your
America there's there's it isn't this it
America's like Tom Brady
we're like he's beat every team in the
league I think at this point we've
defeated we've defeated everybody you
know I'm course I'm kidding
I'll tell you know what our Manny
Pacquiao fight is remember that Pacquiao
Floyd Mayweather fight that should have
happened for 10 years and it never did
that that's that's the United States and
Russia I think by the time we get
together no one's gonna give a [ __ ]
that's my prediction all right old
[ __ ] bald freckled [ __ ] thanks for
cheering me up yeah [ __ ] all yeah I'm
sorry all right enjoy the music and
enjoy the bonus half-hour have a great
weekend your pants and I'll see you on
Monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday
April 18th 2011 [ __ ] I almost said it
perfectly I I was so focusing on saying
2011 clearly I [ __ ] up April did you
catch that
I say April April 18th let me try that
again
bill bill bird starts his podcast oh -
hey what's going on everybody its bill
burr and it's the Monday morning podcast
for April 18 2011 I can't say without
slowing down like some second grader
trying to read out of his book
Greenfield USA did anybody else read
that one I was talking to somebody the
other day that's the last geography
class I had in the United States of
America was in second grade I read a
book called Greenfield USA and I loved
it they talked about all the different
goddamn states you know they talked
about the ha and they chose a little
picture some farmer with the cow holding
a bottle of milk and I remember thinking
wow I wish I lived on a farm and I had a
cow you know my little imagination
running wild then they just cut it out
and now look look at her Americans you
know we can't find [ __ ] anymore
somebody's telling me the other day they
[ __ ] somebody they put quizzing these
college kids and kids were putting like
Delaware like where New Hampshire is you
know that's like that to me that is a
[ __ ] deal-breaker
like if I was dating a girl right
hottest girl on the goddamn planet and
if she thought Delaware was where was
where like New Hampshire was you know I
would I would end that relationship
within eight months because she's hot I
continued [ __ ] her and then hopefully
I'd get tired of her but in the back of
my head it would just be keeping this
[ __ ] doesn't know where the states are
well why would that matter I mean
everybody has the talent everybody has
their good side and their bad side why
don't women just defend every [ __ ]
woman out
is it because there's more of you than
there are of us is that what it is so
you just got to be constantly spinning
broad [ __ ] in a positive way as you guys
just sit there [ __ ] battling with
each other huh is that what it is I
don't know why is my head so [ __ ]
itchy this week are you supposed to wash
your hair everyday I hear different
thing you're not supposed to are you
supposed to let your natural oils
produce is that what it is you know
walking around like some stinky European
you know getting off you [ __ ] awful
pee-wee Herman bicycle what is it with
Europe and those old bicycles is it
because you guys have such small roads
over there is that what it is that you
guys can't progress in a bicycle kind of
way you know is that why we win the Tour
de France every year when we go over
there and all those you ever see the
bikes that they ride even like the bikes
that they ride in the Tour de France the
Italian bikes are terrible horrible
bikes I'm just trying to get them going
just in case I have any Italian [ __ ]
listeners over there bellissimo mangia
mangia you know bad I want to [ __ ] go
to Italy and just gain 900 pounds
evidently you don't because they haven't
[ __ ] with their food over there I've
been reading more and more about food
basically what we eat over here is is it
the closest thing to straight-up poison
I don't even think we're fat lazy [ __ ]
I just think they're poisoning us like I
guess the pasta over there in Italy is
like Jenna doesn't gluten-free
whatever the [ __ ] that means I don't
know what gluten is but evidently you
don't want a lot of it in your pasta and
there's [ __ ] over there it's gluten-free
I don't mean I don't know if that means
there's no gluten over there or the
gluten they have it's not oppressed like
it is in this country I don't know what
it is but all I know is those
[ __ ] over there you know they
just sit there this eat spaghetti all
day they have conversations with the
[ __ ] hanging out of their mouths you
know using that tie as a napkin and
everybody has a Ferrari is that what it
is do you guys know what I did this week
you know I did this [ __ ] week I
he went down and I finally decided I'm
getting a second car I decided to [ __ ]
it I'm telling you that [ __ ] over there
in Japan really [ __ ] with me you know
considering I live on a fault line all
right I realize I need to live for today
and I also realize I need to be prepared
in case some of that [ __ ] went down so
my first step in securing my perimeter
is all them good old boys do down the
south everybody makes fun of them hey
we're all just Bunch do the rednecks
right those rednecks are the smartest
[ __ ] on the planet as far as
they are ready for when the [ __ ] goes
down they're ready all right they got
trucks they got guns they know how to
kill [ __ ] skin it gut it cook it eat it
[ __ ] it
they know how to do all of that they're
not ahead for the hails man they know
how to do that
they live in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere the great thing about living in
the middle of [ __ ] nowhere is you
don't have that many games on your
schedule you know what I mean you live
in the city okay you got a full schedule
of potential zombies and whatever coming
over the [ __ ] goddamn rail trying to
run up the stairs of your apartment okay
I don't care how many [ __ ] bullets
you got you're gonna run out and
eventually they're gonna overrun you
they're gonna take your [ __ ] and [ __ ]
have sex with your dead body Jesus bill
really yeah really that's how it goes
down in the apocalypse those rednecks
they live in the middle of nowhere they
got a big field all around their house
they got like 12 kids so they can all
look out every [ __ ] window who's
kidding who they can put four kids for
their three windows right in each window
on all sides of their little [ __ ]
outhouse and there's no way to sneak up
on you know you got to crawl in your
[ __ ] elbows you're not gonna do it
you're gonna leave them alone they live
in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere but
when you live in the city that's when
you got to get worried you know unless
you're lucky enough to live in a gated
community gated community you know why
did I say that twice pick up the papers
pick up the papers you know the gated
community you know either you're so
famous
or you've stolen so much from regular
people that you feel the need to live
behind a [ __ ] wall you know have you
guys noticed that on Google Maps that
when you try to take the little guy and
bring him down into a gated community
they won't let it do it you know why are
they so [ __ ] special what did they do
you know can you guys do me a favor can
can you guys my listeners now you should
not do this you shouldn't do this I'm
not advocating doing this wink wink but
uh why don't you spray-paint something
on the wall outside a gated community
that just makes those people not feel so
goddamn comfortable you know I'm sick of
them being cowsy smug [ __ ] just sitting
in there thinking everything's gonna be
alright just do something don't do
anything to any of them just spray-paint
something crazy like hey [ __ ] you're
next
where's the baler I don't know what the
[ __ ] just write something that's vague
that kind of includes all of them so
they don't know who's a target just so
they're a little bit nervous when
they're in there eating their
gluten-free pasta that they have flown
in you know wow so anyway so you know
what I did I went down to this Jesus
what the [ __ ] did I just do oh I thought
I just hit the a the erase button No so
anyway so I went down to this this place
where they specialize in old Mustangs
and I went down there and I was gonna I
was gonna order one and just say [ __ ]
this is the year I want this is what I
want on it tell me how much it [ __ ]
cost and I'm gonna book some road gigs
and uh dude the level of Catholic guilt
even though I don't even [ __ ] I don't
even believe in that [ __ ] anymore I
don't believe in it okay I don't know if
you go somewhere when you die or any
that type of ship and I know all this
[ __ ] religious stuff other than the
basics the ten commandments which you
know you really could have made one
commandment just don't be a [ __ ] right
isn't that what it's all about don't be
a [ __ ]
don't take the Lord's name in vain don't
disrespect your parents don't steal my
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] my wife don't want to
[ __ ] my wife don't be a [ __ ] what's
wrong with you
Hey look at me yeah you you're a [ __ ]
cut it out that basically sums up the
foundation of every every religion and
then then it turns into guys right
Buddha I like Buddha that's a good one
you know some happy fat [ __ ] just
sitting there all jolly you can't even
see his dick and he's still happy you
know there's something empowering about
that Jesus I'm not into you know I you
know and it's not even his [ __ ] pot
smoking you know goddamn hacky sack vibe
that he's putting out you know his
goddamn robe made out of ganja it's not
even that it's it's he I hate the
[ __ ] martyr aspect of my religion you
know I did it for you I hate that [ __ ]
you know somebody slaps you in the face
you turn the other cheek
do it again will that make you feel
better the meek shall inherit the earth
it's just it's just a blueprint for
being a [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] can't stand it
and then it's Jewish religion I don't
know [ __ ] about it I just know when you
get really into it you got to grow those
curly-q Elvis sideburns and then you got
to wear that little uh that little round
thing on the back of your head you know
and then wear the same shirt in the same
pants every [ __ ] day or the same
style you know what are you [ __ ]
Albert Einstein are you over there
working on theories of relativity you're
not you're not all right go get yourself
a nice shirt I had a little [ __ ]
color to your wardrobe can you can you
[ __ ] have a little bit of fun um what
else oh then the Muslim religion I don't
want to get down on my knees every day
of four and the after I'm [ __ ] old
my knees hurt I want to do that [ __ ] I
gotta carry a yoga man around everywhere
I [ __ ] go and try and figure out you
know which way is south east or whatever
the hell up spot I don't want to do that
I don't [ __ ] do any of that
so I think that pretty much cosine Tala
gee that's the last one
you know that one I would actually join
because there's just something funny
about you know being a fly in the wall
hanging out with that level of weirdo
you know I think there the weirdest out
of all of them
Scientologists just because the [ __ ]
religious like all other religions were
started that seems way the [ __ ] back in
the day so there's this vagueness that
there's no proof that it's complete
[ __ ] you know but l ron Hubbard has
a quote if you want to make you want to
become a millionaire start a religion he
basically admits that he kind of just
made all this [ __ ] up
said that he was the guy he did it in
like the 40s you know and they're all
sitting around there waiting for a
[ __ ] spaceship to show up I just want
to go down there and have a really
[ __ ] intense conversation with Tom
Cruise you know and just see if I can
get him going you know what I would do
is I would just say that was a little
confused about a certain aspect of my
life just to watch him go into [ __ ]
motivational speaker mode you know
laughing maniacally you know Scientology
they got in all religions they have
those giant cavernous buildings so when
somebody laughs maniacally maniacally
you get the [ __ ] amazing acoustics
you know not the same acoustics that are
like in Jimmy Page's stairwell when they
recorded the drums for when the levee
breaks you know good those drums sound
just imagine somebody laughing in that
[ __ ] stairwell you know what should I
add some reverb here and give you a
maniacal laugh that would be too much
[ __ ] work um anyways so this is what
I did this week so I went down there to
go [ __ ] see if I could get a Mustang
and the place was closed and then I'm
driving back and I'm like what's that a
sign was that a sign that I shouldn't
have done it and it's like no bill
that's a sign that you're a dumb [ __ ]
and he didn't check to see what their
hours were so whatever whatever so this
is what I did this week all right I did
a lot of [ __ ] this week by the way let
me let me let me remember before I tell
you that
[ __ ] story I did Kevin James podcasts
this week and that is gonna be I say
Kevin James Kevin Smith
I think Kevin Smith oh oh Jesus that's
gonna be one of these [ __ ] weeks
isn't it I did Kevin Smith's podcast
it's gonna be uploaded today he does
actually he did he didn't show up he was
sick so I actually sat in for him which
is really nerve-wracking because I you
know remind me where like what like the
Ice Capades when I saw him in 1976 at
the old Boston God I saw him in the late
70s actually and Dorothy Hamill didn't
show up and we were all [ __ ] upset
and they had some other chick substitute
and everybody [ __ ] booed so I was
worried that these these comic book
reading sci-fi fans were going to boo me
and they didn't
and fortunately Ralph Garman his co-host
[ __ ] hilarious he made me feel
totally comfortable I did the show with
him and that that podcast is gonna be up
today alright see you getting to two
podcasts from me today
all right you're probably gonna be
completely sick of him I'm getting
overexposed in the podcast world I did
Doug Benson's last week I did I did
Kevin Smith's on Saturday it airs today
and on Wednesday I'm gonna do the Sklar
brothers I'm making the podcast rounds
people I think I am becoming a [ __ ]
go to guest in the podcasting world you
know like back in the day when somebody
cancelled I'll [ __ ] we need a guest back
in the day in the Tonight Show who they
go with a they they bring in George
Gobel they bring in Burt Reynolds can he
do that [ __ ] Cannonball Run laughs
right that's what I'm becoming in the
podcast world I did Joe Rogan's like
[ __ ] three weeks ago who else am i
doing
I think I'm doing Chris Porter's coming
up
you know I am just doing all kinds of
free work here in the podcasting world
people that's what it's all about
speaking of which speaking of which I
actually on the MM podcast page for the
first time ever we have installed a
donation button so if you want to stop
listening to me cry like a [ __ ] feel
like you know whatever if you want to
donate to the podcast I'd really
appreciate it
because this is a ton of work I do
appreciate the fact that I do get to
communicate to you guys but you know if
you want to [ __ ] donate or whatever
we're starting to take this thing to the
next level I came up on the new Monday
morning podcast logo or actually at the
real thing as I paid somebody to do it
we got t-shirts and [ __ ] like that we
got some merchandise coming so so that
way the podcast can continue to be free
if you want to donate a buck whatever
you want to donate 5 bucks [ __ ] six
bucks 350 whatever the [ __ ] you want to
donate if you go to the mmm podcast page
mmm podcast com it's on the right hand
side just under the Twitter Facebook
buttons you'll see donate just click on
there and go right through PayPal
whatever all right
donation only just like a church can i
guilty guys how can i guilt you like
Jesus and he said it Thunder you earth
go [ __ ] it yourself and what else I
really got to get this [ __ ] out of the
way I have to make sure that I do treat
my career like a business at some point
here so I do have to hype a couple of
things here all right uh my pop my web
guy said remind everyone to follow you
on twitter
he made a less a list here cuz I blow
this every week all right
follow me on twitter at bill burr I
believe that's my twitter now I know my
[ __ ] Twitter name it's either at bill
burr or at billboard.com I think it's
just at bill burr be URR I tweet I talk
about things I Twitter I don't tweet
that's the masculine way let's see
homophobic way of tweeting you Twitter
what else who also feel also tell them
to feel free to hit the share
but when you post videos on your
Facebook page oh yeah I'm trying to get
my Facebook page the fan page trying to
get those numbers up prevented 2,500
people since Tuesday we're trying to
keep that thing going you know what
people I'm actually for the first time
in my career I'm gonna try to use the
internet to my advantage
see up until this point I really had no
game plan it was like I'm just gonna go
on here I'm gonna say a bunch of stupid
[ __ ] for a [ __ ] and you know if
people like it they [ __ ] like it man
and if they find it they [ __ ] find it
and I realize that you know what there's
9 zillion podcasts out there I need to I
gotta advertise I got a [ __ ] I got a
do what the [ __ ] I got to do here I'm
finally realizing that you know turning
43 in June you know at some point I
would like to feel that if you know I
don't know what if I was to lose my
pancreas
I could still have enough money
squirreled away that I could I could
afford oatmeal for breakfast for the
rest of my life isn't that what
everybody wants don't you guys have a
don't you have a number in your [ __ ]
head
what's your number you know you guys
watch Breaking Bad you guys watch that
[ __ ] show do you know uh Eisenberg
his mr. white his his big number is six
hundred grand he can get six hundred
grand in cash squirreled away into the
bottom of his house if he kicks the
bucket his family's gonna be okay see so
I don't have a family I got my girl all
right and I got my dog all right but I
plan on [ __ ] living I don't have a
terminal disease like mr. white actually
he's in remission on that show sorry I'm
getting a little [ __ ] Breaking Bad
I'm going a little geek here for that
show um excuse me what would be my I
have no [ __ ] idea what my figure
would be definitely six you need six
figures right would you guys do that you
know cuz everybody wants a [ __ ] house
here's something for you everybody wants
a house all right oh wait let me explain
that [ __ ] real quick cuz I don't even
think I explained it am I on my Facebook
page the fan page we understand
posting some some of the funny videos
the YouTube ones and if you like them
only if you like him you think they're
funny just share them with the rest of
your friends and then hopefully they'll
see that and they'll be like well who
the [ __ ] is this redheaded character and
then they'll go onto my page and if they
like my comedy then they [ __ ] add me
you know and then maybe I can catch up
with some of these other comedians out
there who are playing these gigantic
venues with with with [ __ ] sparklers
that come down at the end of their shows
right people I want to sell out
everybody that there's an assignment for
you this we come up with a catchphrase
for me what is something that I can see
Gator dead what can I die nomad what can
I say
at the end of my jokes huh maybe I can
just do that haha at the everywhere
would that be enough and then I sell ha
t-shirts at the end is that what I gotta
do you know what this really is people I
know what you're thinking is is Bill
just gonna give up all [ __ ] integrity
you know what it is is I need a [ __ ]
vacation I need a [ __ ] vacation it's
coming up in June first two weeks of
June I'm on vacation and I know what you
think and you're gonna still do the
podcast man of course I'm gonna I'm not
gonna leave you hanging I'm [ __ ] I'm
gonna I want to go to the middle of
nowhere I want to get a cabin that's
what I want to do there any rednecks
listen to this [ __ ]
anyone can you recommend me some [ __ ]
who's gonna be the first podcast
listener to take me hunting all right
and you got to know I don't know how to
shoot anything but I will [ __ ] shoot
something I don't have a problem killing
an animal I don't if I'm out there
they'll don't be enough mosquitoes that
I'll be in enough of an ornery mood you
know I already told you I could shoot a
[ __ ] deer as long as it didn't have
any deer friends standing around or any
little kids doze whatever it is you know
how's kid who if it was a really
majestic looking one with a bunch of
[ __ ] where they call 12 pointer or
something I couldn't shoot that either
we just had to be a stupid-looking deer
just stand and they have [ __ ] just
you know you could just tell a bear is
gonna Club it over the head soon right
isn't that our bears kill their [ __ ]
their prey they like picked up a stick
they start bashing it over the [ __ ]
head like Hannibal Lecter anyways did I
finish typing everything I think that's
it oh and this week I'm also gonna be at
the Pabst Theater in Milwaukee Wisconsin
there's only a little only a few tickets
left for that one and the Detroit show
is sold out so I want to thank both
those blue-collar towns that I'm finally
making my way to I got there without
having to have a puppet or a catchphrase
people very proud of that but now I want
to play I want to play Tiger Stadium so
I need I need a catchphrase everybody
come on and I'll try him out - I'm not
beyond it I will try them out next week
on the podcast come up with a [ __ ]
horrific one oh wait a minute didn't
what's-his-face already do this Ricky
Gervais stand he do that then he do a
show yeah I used to watch that show he
was an extra are you having a laugh
that's such a great [ __ ] and that's the
perfect that's just that's brilliant
writing right there that they I don't
know freaking Gervase came up but I
don't know who came up with that but
that is just so [ __ ] that is that's
just perfect god damn it that's just but
I'm not even funny right now I'm just
sitting here just [ __ ] not just you
know you know what I'm doing right now I
am I'm sitting right now on my bed
laying sideways on my bed lying on my
side with my head in my hand you know
like I'm posing for Playgirl magazine
you know like the the Burt Reynolds pose
back in the 70s look at me
I think I think I'm getting I think I'm
getting a [ __ ] ego got an extra
twenty five hundred friends on my
Facebook page I'm telling people to
follow me on Twitter look at me I'm not
even being funny this week I'm just
hyping [ __ ] and we got the new lady bill
burr tank tops coming up I can't [ __ ]
do that [ __ ] alright let's plow ahead
here
let's get into the podcast shall we I
have so much [ __ ] to talk about I'm
ready twenty five [ __ ] minutes into
this thing let's try to blow through
this quickly my parents came to town
this week this weekend came out here to
visit
and you know the deal you feel like
you're an adult you feel like you're a
man you're a guy's guy you're driving
down the street and your hybrid with
your [ __ ] arm hanging out the window
and you made sure you put sunblock on so
you didn't get cancer because you're a
[ __ ] right you think you got the
world figured out then all of a sudden
your parents show up and immediately you
turn into a kid again you you want their
approval so you know I don't have any
kids I don't have anything to show that
I am living for anybody other than
myself
I'm living a selfish artists life I play
guitar I play drums I play hockey I
[ __ ] tell jokes I [ __ ] do whatever
the hell I want to do I just sit around
all day staring at my ball it's great
it's [ __ ] great I don't know why the
[ __ ] you guys yeah I know I and you
chose love I don't know why you ever
gotten married I don't know why you ever
had kids and then you [ __ ] chained
yourself to your cubicle I don't know
why you did it but evidently it's worth
it because everybody I know has kids
gonna tell you yeah I thought the work
all day you know every morning my boss
comes in and slaps me in the face with
this tie calls me a [ __ ] and I say
thank you sir may I have another and my
[ __ ] hate my job oh I tell you when I
get home when I get home and I just see
my kid it just I gave them whatever they
say all that [ __ ] horseshit and the
thing is is I know it's true I know it's
true I know when I have a kid I'm not
gonna give a [ __ ] how I look anymore you
know I'm not gonna moisturize I'm going
to be walking around and old clothes and
old [ __ ] gym shoes that's my biggest
fear if I ever become a parent I'll just
become a parent you know and just dress
like [ __ ] and drive that old car I don't
want to do it why why if you become a
parent wife Jerry Seinfeld has Porsches
what am I talking about see there's a
smart [ __ ] guy
you know he made his dream come true he
made his half a [ __ ] billion he got a
fleet of Porsches and then he went down
to the gym he picked out some chick I
don't give a
if you [ __ ] engage let's go sweetie I
got half a billion dollars come over
here come over here and ride my rich
[ __ ] right then he starts pumping out
the [ __ ] kids late 40s early 50s
people that's if you're in your early
20s that's how you do it that's how you
do it you make a million first then you
grab some [ __ ] by her [ __ ] hair you
drag her up the stairs and you say
listen woman I know you want shiny [ __ ]
I can buy you shiny [ __ ] all right
so make a decision go ahead and choose
love you get you fall in and out of it
during the relationship you know it's
gonna wear off and then way you're gonna
be you're gonna be sitting there and
some [ __ ] house some drab ass [ __ ]
house Cheerios in your hair
bunch of little ones running around and
then what or you can choose me shiny
[ __ ] you want a nice shiny kitchen
counter with a shiny fridge you know I'm
50 years old I've been working for 35
[ __ ] years I have no dependents I can
buy you the shiny [ __ ] you want so why
don't you come over here
and ride my half a century old [ __ ] you
know take my [ __ ] dusty semen
fertilize you and then we'll have a
couple of [ __ ] kids you know and you
can be the one who plays with them and
I'll just sit here in a [ __ ] old
sweater rocking back and forth going I
did it I did it eating pot cookies
whatever the [ __ ] I want to do I don't
give a [ __ ] I have enough money for help
that's my game playing people as I sit
here in a one-bedroom apartment in my
early 40s and sweatpants and a [ __ ]
t-shirt I'm still holding on to that
dream people anyways the [ __ ] was so my
parents come to town that's what the
[ __ ] I'm trying to tell us it's what
it's what I'm really trying to talk
about here my parents come to town and
so I don't have any kids I don't have
anything to show them I'm driving a
[ __ ] hybrid nothing I'm doing is
really that impressive
so what do I do I just start taking them
out to restaurants you know that that
was the only card I had to play look at
all the cool places I know where to eat
that's all I have people you double my
age I'm 84 42 years of living on this
planet that's all I can show my parents
is places to eat so I've been actually
been doing really good with the hiking
taking my [ __ ] awesome dog for hikes
and then I come home and I have a big
bowl of [ __ ] oatmeal you know and I
have it the real way I just have olt
meal like a prisoner of war just slop it
right in the bowl throw a little bit of
raisins on it that's the only [ __ ]
excitement I allow during my breakfast
moment you know all you [ __ ] out there
trying to lose weight what do you do you
make something healthy and then you
[ __ ] add your drugs to it don't you
your sugars your salts put a little milk
in there I'm gonna put a scoop ice cream
on top of what you have for breakfast I
add oatmeal I'm telling you it's my
metabolism no it isn't you cheating [ __ ]
stop putting up the the food steroids
into your healthy food you got to sit
there and you you know what you got to
do is you got to get that [ __ ] you
got to get that uh that desire that
craving out of your body you know like
you guys if you watch my stand-up
specials you guys realize that I have a
sweet tooth I hate that about myself
and but you know what it was I I [ __ ]
just stopped eating them and it took
about a week every night if you driving
home going I want a piece of cake what
the [ __ ] is was your birthday bill the
[ __ ] wrong with me I want a piece of
cake
or like a pine ice cream I just wanted
it right but then after a [ __ ] week
your body it just gets that craving out
of your system now I don't want it
anymore hey you know what's funny is now
that it's out of my system I walked into
this place the other day and they had
you know to go in and get this this
three-bean salad you know
because I'm really I'm trying to get the
booze weight off you know because I quit
boozing but I just kept eating like an
idiot I'm trying to make get my head
back down to the size it should be right
so I'm going in that order that and I'm
sitting there
right in the front they got like you
know seven different kinds of cakes and
all this [ __ ] and because I wasn't
craving sugar like it looked it looked
bizarre it looked like clown food all
these bright colors and [ __ ] like why
the why would you even eat that [ __ ] you
know a week before or if I had some some
bad food I would have [ __ ] had my
face pressed up against the glass trying
to you know just one eat half the cake
so whatever so I've been doing great
with people with my my diet and all that
type of [ __ ] that my parents come to
town and that's all I had I was just
like I you know I just started taking
him out I [ __ ] head you know a couple
of cheeseburgers I was eating a [ __ ]
Grand Slam breakfast last night at some
50s diner took him out to some French
restaurant eaten beef bourguignon out of
this stew pot that looks like the Jolly
Green Giant made the [ __ ] and I'm at
that age couple of days eating bad again
like 5 [ __ ] pounds and I got a big
doughy white stomach again it's killing
me so anyways this is how [ __ ]
hilarious my parents are they come out
to visit me in Hollywood all right where
do you think they wanted to go what
tourist attraction go ahead I'll give
you a second to guess what are you gonna
guess to go look at the Hollywood Walk
of Fame all those stars on the sidewalk
Mann's Chinese Theater Hollywood Bowl
Sunset Strip go down look at the
Paramount Studios get their picture
taken in front of the Hollywood sign now
you know where they wanted to go they
wanted to go to the Ronald Reagan
Library the Ronald Reagan Presidential
Library how [ __ ] awesome is that you
know you know the deal in it whenever
you live in a city for a while if you
live in st. Louis every time you come
there what have people want to go to the
[ __ ] Arts you don't want to go there
you don't give a [ __ ] they want to ride
that little stupid elevator up to the
top you don't want to do it but you got
to do it you live in New York some
douchebag wants to go to the top of the
Empire State Building you don't want to
do it so my parents came out here and
I'm thinking out god I got to take them
to the usual spots and
said that they wanted to go to the
Ronald Reagan Presidential Library and I
was like that that's in Hollywood
they're like no no no it's uh out west
west of LA and I was like you know what
I'll [ __ ] do that I'll do that in a
second and I went out there man I had a
great goddamn time um that's something
you ought to do you ought to go to a
Presidential Library it's [ __ ]
hilarious especially if it's a president
where you were alive when all the [ __ ]
that happened went down so then you can
go into their library cuz the libraries
of hilarious I don't give a [ __ ] who it
is they are gonna make that guy look I
just like the third library I've been to
the JFK I've been to the Richard Nixon
and I've been to the now the Ronald
Reagan none of these were my ideas I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't want to go to
these things I'm just always with people
who want to go to this [ __ ] and what
I've noticed with the libraries is they
just make the person seem just like the
greatest [ __ ] person ever like
evidently Ronald Reagan was the greatest
guy ever which amazing because I thought
it was Richard Nixon and before that I
thought it was [ __ ] JFK they just you
know they had one part of it they had
this whole you know that whole just say
no to drugs
thing that they came up with was a
miserable failure I remember it
I remember that people used to make fun
just say no okay well that solves the
crack epidemic when somebody asks you
for drugs just they know okay meanwhile
we're gonna cut funding for anything
that would help you get out of your
financial [ __ ] problem in the inner
city you know and then the one viable
commodity the drugs which you either
sell and make money or you take to
[ __ ] numb the pain of living in a
goddamn war zone just say no to that
just just say you don't want to do it
and then continue going to an incredibly
unsafe shitty school that we're not
gonna help to try to make anything
better so they butt in
library it was just an absolute smashing
success and they was showing her just
say no and her hugging some inner-city
children and the dress she wore this is
just a Nancy Reagan part and they
actually you know was the best part they
had and they had to just say no board
game which I was trying to take a
picture of but the [ __ ] security kept
looking at me you weren't allowed to
take pictures in the Ronald Reagan
Presidential Library and I just wanted
to see like what you know I just want I
want to I gotta look that up on the
internet I want to know what happens how
do you lose that game do you like slowly
become a junkie as you play that game
and they're like you know at the end of
the board game is there one gated
community
nice neighborhood we live with all the
banker [ __ ] and then there's another
one we make the left turn and you just
in some [ __ ] slum that they cut
funding to is that basically it so
having gone to that and then the Reagan
thing was just like you know obviously I
like the [ __ ] he did where he
strengthened our military you know and
then the Russians tried to strengthen
their melech military and then they
[ __ ] went bankrupt that was a great
[ __ ] move ended up being the worst
thing for this country though I think
cuz you need an adversary you need one
because if you don't then you just
become a greenie [ __ ] because there's
nobody stopping you from just [ __ ]
eatin every piece of cake that's on the
goddamn table but anyways so I haven't
gone to the Reagan one I now want to go
to the Bill Clinton one because I want
to see how they spin all that Monica
Lewinsky I finger [ __ ] some fat [ __ ] in
the White House I just got to see cuz
they got to address it cuz he gotten
peached
he's only only two presidents in history
have ever gotten impeached it's him and
some other [ __ ] guy forget the other
guy everybody thinks it's [ __ ] Nixon
but he did Nixon resigned before that
[ __ ] happened he pulled a Manny Ramirez
I'm going to Spain I'm out see but I
don't know man it was really it was as
much as I'm making fun of Reagan and
that type of [ __ ] like you know I don't
buy into Democrats or Republicans they
all serve the same [ __ ] guys it
doesn't make a difference especially at
this point but it was just interesting
to see
I'd like I'm still into the memorabilia
like the creepiest part of the Reagan
Library is your [ __ ] go through it
and remember when John Hinckley tried to
kill him
they you walk into this one part they go
this is the assassination part of the
Ronald Reagan [ __ ] library and you
walk in there and there's three screens
all showing the exact same thing and
they go it'll start in ten seconds and
they just show the raw footage of Reagan
walking out and this guy squeezing off
six [ __ ] shots you know Brady got
shot in the head thank God it was a 22
or as he would have been dead but uh a
DC police officer and then a Secret
Service Officer all got shot and then
Reagan took one that record off the car
and caught him so it's just the raw
footage there's no like you know like
[ __ ] Tom Brokaw go on tonight Nightly
News Ronald Reagan was your country to
be sure there wasn't any of that they
just showed it like he was standing
there
it was the creepiest [ __ ] ever just he's
walking out waving and then it pop pop
pop pop pop and then everybody just died
get about him I gotta get out of here
get him out there and the car [ __ ]
drives away you're like Jesus Christ so
then you walk into the next room which
is like 10 feet away and there's no door
okay and now you're looking at the suit
that Reagan wore when he got shot and
there's a bullet hit the [ __ ] the
coat the side of the coat and then you
know the [ __ ] assassination the
attempt the raw footage is playing every
ten seconds so now you're looking at the
suit and then I'll send you just here
and it just kept playing it just was
like dude what the [ __ ] and I that was
the only part of the library I didn't
like it's like I got it
Jesus Christ and I had to leave but the
best part of the library and I got
pictures of this up on the mmm
podcast.com is they [ __ ] had Air
Force one a 757 the entire [ __ ] plane
they had it encased within the building
and you could go
you could go on the [ __ ] thing and
they had the place where the guys sat
with the you know the nuclear devices
turn your key this is what blew my mind
too when you got on the plane is you
know now we're just starting to get the
technology where us regular people can
be on the internet and use phones and
[ __ ] they had that technology on Air
Force One back in the day when [ __ ]
Reagan Carter all those guys you could
you could pick up a rotary phone and
call the Kremlin whoever the [ __ ] you
needed to talk to on a goddamn rotary
phone so that means that that
technology's at least thirty five years
ahead of us that that that would be the
only reason why I would ever want to be
President I just want to see what like
Obama's cell phone looks like the
capabilities of it you know anybody was
any of that [ __ ] interesting all
right let's move on here uh real quick
and I'm gonna start I'm gonna get into
the whole [ __ ] uh questions for the
week Oh coming up this next week Tribeca
Film Festival starts and me Robert
Kelley and Joe DeRosa have a movie that
got selected a short film called cheap
and somebody sent me an email about it
it said hey bill are you doing so do
just watch the trailer for cheat and man
I got to tell you it looks quite good
it's really cool to see you Bobby and
Joe and even dumb Foss doing something
serious like this is it going to make a
run across theaters what are the chances
of it being on DVD sometime this is the
deal it's just short film so we'll
probably try and put it in other film
festivals but we're currently writing a
book me Joe and Bobby and that's based
off of the movie and the book will be
out next year beginning part of next
year hopefully and in the back of the
book the full movie will be available so
though the the movie itself sheet will
come with the book and I can't tell you
what it's about because I don't want to
ruin the [ __ ] movie so I'm glad you
think that it looks cool and anybody in
the New York area please go on to the
Tribeca website that I don't have of
course as always I don't have any
information I'll have it next week next
week by the way I'm a Bobby and Joe
DeRosa
on my podcast the first time ever
there's gonna be three people on my
podcast two guests at the same time I'll
see how I handled that I went out and I
bought a third mic people I'm ready to
do it
so what else what else did I want to
talk about how about the Bruins huh how
about the Bruins digging themself a
[ __ ] hole I still have faith I got a
feeling the Bruins are gonna go into
Montreal tonight they're gonna kick the
[ __ ] out of those fake [ __ ] Parisian
[ __ ] up there you know what's
annoying me it's not even knowing me
that we're losing to the Canadiens
because I know I I don't know why people
were picking the Bruins to win the Cup I
just wish we're still missing at least
two major pieces to have a championship
run
but what's killing me is they're makin
Carey Price look like he's Ken Dryden
and he isn't he isn't these are the
first two playoff games this guy is ever
[ __ ] won in his entire career all
right the last time we saw this guy in
the playoffs we beat him four games in a
[ __ ] row what's going on now is the
Canadians they have dared their forwards
and the defenseman that blocking shots
they and the Bruins just a plan the
dumbest [ __ ] hockey taking slap shots
there's nobody in front here you go
Kerry
is there enough ice between me and you
so you can get a nice bead on this puck
[ __ ] horrific and I know a lot of
Bruins fans have pissed the chera didn't
play Game two they said he was
dehydrated and everybody went oh these
[ __ ] European players are such
[ __ ]
drink some Gatorade I think that that
they couldn't say that he was puking and
[ __ ] his brains out probably for 24
hours I think he had what I had like a
month ago so hopefully he'll come back
and they'll crunch another one of those
[ __ ] [ __ ] Canadian players into the
boards and then they can [ __ ] make a
goddamn federal case out of it I don't
know the series is not over there's no
[ __ ] way there's no way it's over
I have faith we got a [ __ ] win we got
to win tonight all right that's it and
other than that I've just been watching
the these are my predictions
I think the Lightning are going to be
Pittsburgh
I think I think the Bruins are gonna
come back and beat the Canadians that's
my heart talking Flyers will beat the
Sabres who else these are easy to Troy's
gonna be Phoenix Vancouver's gonna beat
Chicago and wait wait wait what Ron do
you think San Jose is gonna choke this
year everybody do you think the Kings
are gonna come back and beat him I have
no [ __ ] idea alright let's plow ahead
here my finals are the obvious i think
it's i think the Flyers no what about
the capless think the Capitals have
finally pushed through I got a funny
feeling the Rangers are gonna beat the
Capitals I felt that even though they
lost Game one
I thought the Rangers were gonna come
back and steal Game two but when they
did and they went up two games to none I
that's when I was like I guess the
Capitals are gonna do it this year but
now that they won Game three I don't
know I don't know there's a lot of
pressure on the Capitals a lot of [ __ ]
pressure on those [ __ ] [ __ ] in DC
alright let's plow ahead here alright
very happy stay-at-home-dad writes dear
bill after listening to one of your
recent podcasts and also watching let it
go I felt compelled to write in I have
major issues with stay-at-home moms
complaining about how hard it is Oh Jay
age perhaps this topic is played out but
I think my situation may bring a new
light on the matter I'm a stay-at-home
dad I'll spare you how he became a
stay-at-home dad and just tell you that
it's terrific I love it
I do all of what you'd expect clean do
laundry
yard work cook homework with the kids
and pickups and drop-offs and have no
problem with any of it dude that sounds
like a [ __ ] vacation
wouldn't it be hot hanging out with
[ __ ] kids I know it sucks when
they're babies but once they become like
just like little people you know and
plus all the technology that they have
to [ __ ] in case your children you
know what I mean just like put up those
little barricades you can make those
little rubber rooms so they can't hurt
themselves and then you stick like the
Teletubbies on and that's like you know
LSD for kids and they're just sitting
there tripping is you're in the other
room making you
a little Scotch anyways yeah there's no
boss and everyday is like [ __ ]
Saturday you get to hang at your house
you get to sleep in your bone bed I know
the grass is always greener but that
sounds [ __ ] awesome anyways he says
I'm a pretty organized person so the
house always looks good and I've oh and
I've always been a good cook
now I'm an even better one my my wife
comes home
two great meals in a clean house and at
the end of her day needs only to eat
relax and hang out with their daughter
another child is on the way this July
what does your wife do for a living that
she can support you guys live a nice
that's even better if she's got some
insane [ __ ] job one of the biggest
problems with my situation is when she
decides to reclaim one of the
traditional female roles around the
house this happens periodically about
once a month usually less it must be
primitive genetic code that kicks in
every so often when it does my world
gets [ __ ] suddenly I'm told nothing is
where it should be in the kitchen and he
and I and we need to organize it or that
pots aren't good enough or that [ __ ] is
too high on the shelves I have a foot
I'm like a foot taller than my wife you
know what happened with this with this
reading here I was just thinking how
well I was reading now in my [ __ ]
head and I'm screwing up let's try to
regroup here bill alright or worse when
she decides to go food shopping come
home with [ __ ] we don't need or we have
never eaten before because she felt we
should try it or worse yet when she
decides to cook a meal her cooking isn't
bad but when she cooks I I don't get the
night off my job is to show her where
everything is spices dry goods pots etc
and also to reach [ __ ] she can't when
she's done I spend the next day
reorganizing everything to my liking
dude you got to be like a broad there
you got to claim the kitchen
now don't go shoo she'll get out of here
I'll do this that's what you got to do
your problem is is you're letting her in
see women can shoo guys out of the
kitchen because we don't usually most
guys don't want to be in there and in
the end we always try to keep in a good
mood so maybe you'll blow us that night
you know women they don't have that kind
of sex drive you know and plus they
always have the option of banging
someone at work if they
- you know with absolutely no game
whatsoever other than just [ __ ]
wearing some hoary shoes and hiking
their skirt up they don't even need an
open inline you know their lives are so
[ __ ] easy
other than [ __ ] having to squeeze a
kid out that's the one thing I'll give
you those nine months of hell but you
get paid back you get to tee off twelve
to [ __ ] twenty yards in front of me
at the golf course people hold doors for
you you don't have to pay for a movie
you show a little cleavage you get free
drinks all night what the [ __ ] are you
broads bitching about alright plow ahead
here so anyways guys I don't go to her
office rearranging [ __ ] on occasion on
the occasions I drop by oh Jesus
so don't laugh at me when I tell you
certain things go in certain areas of
the fridge and why it's neat I know I do
it I totally get it
I'm not giving you [ __ ] he said I used
to complain out loud to her about it now
I just grin and bear it on occasion on
the occasion it happens I figure it's
better not to rot brought the boat
unless she wises up and sees how good I
have it dude you live in the [ __ ]
life you know what you are dude you're
basically retired and your wife is out
there providing your pension I think
that's phenomenal I think that is
absolutely phenomenal and I don't know
why more women don't enjoy being
stay-at-home mom said I'm not trying to
be as chauvinistic Pig here you know
okay those first few years suck without
a doubt but then you got to understand
once they they go to school all right
they start going to school at 9:00 and
they get off at 3:00
you got six hours in the middle of the
day to do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do and you know something and that's one
of those classic points that you bring
up to women or stay-at-home moms and
they freak the [ __ ] out and then they go
oh you know then they try to make those
six hours difficult like all the [ __ ]
and [ __ ] they have to do it's like what
do you have to do what exactly do you
have to do you got the kid dressed and
you fed him now he's at [ __ ] school
someone else is why
and the kid for the next six hours what
exactly is it that you have to [ __ ]
do laundry oh my god that that's got to
be so difficult to separate whites from
the darks stick it in a [ __ ] machine
and press a button and have it clean it
for you
where is the you just if those six hours
aren't enough for you you're just
creating work for yourself you know you
can actually be sitting on the couch
drinking a margarita as a machine washes
the [ __ ] clothes it's not that big a
[ __ ] deal it really isn't
go out food shopping and you get to go
out during the day when there's no
traffic and there's nobody around you go
to the post office he just sort of putts
around town
your little Maybury town that's a
[ __ ] dream you know I don't know I
just think that you know that just seems
like a [ __ ] awesome life and then the
kids come home and it gets loud or
whatever but they're your kids
you love them you make them [ __ ]
sandwiches you know and then then what I
mean how much longer do they go you put
them to bed by [ __ ] 8:00 they get
home at like what 3:30 I I just don't
understand what what what what the big
[ __ ] deal is I just don't get it I
really don't get it somebody please it
you don't understand it's every [ __ ]
day that's another thing too and then at
the end of all of that bitching it's
like well you didn't have to be a mom
you know it's very easy there's condoms
there's the pill there's a whole bunch
of prophylactics all different kinds you
can choose from you [ __ ] chose the
job and now you're bitching about it
what is your [ __ ] problem Jesus
Christ you don't you don't to go food
shopping just go buy a jar of peanut
butter and a big giant jar of jelly
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches there
you go bang you can do that like three
four times a week they don't give a [ __ ]
big glass of milk some cheese and
crackers
while you're overthinking it ladies you
over [ __ ] thinking that I've really
no I don't think it's that [ __ ] hard
I think you guys are full of [ __ ] you
know what it is just like how this guy
said at the end of his email where he's
just sitting there grinning and burying
it and he doesn't want to rock the boat
unless she wises up to see how good he
has it I think that that's why those
stay-at-home moms I'm not talking about
working moms I'm talking about
stay-at-home moms I think that that's
why they complain that much the only
complaint there are aspects I do
understand the fact that you guys sit
there talking googoo gaga talk to the
whole [ __ ] day and you just want to
hang out with an adult at some point
that would drive me a little batshit but
you know everything has you know its ups
and downs and I just don't see the
[ __ ] downside as being that that's
steep with that job
I really don't anyways
sitting there making macaroni trees you
know taking them to the [ __ ]
playground and pushing them on a swing I
mean how difficult is that that's
difficult that's harder than sitting in
a cubicle having somebody coming over
and telling you what to do do you ever
think what's great about being a
stay-at-home mom is you're your own
[ __ ] boss nobody's telling you what
to do nobody's ten don't even [ __ ]
tell me your kids are telling you what
to do okay get you goddamn kids in order
alright that's what they invented sticks
for you know slap him around a little
bit you put the fear of death in him and
then they shut the [ __ ] up that's what
my mom used to do she had a paddle my
dad had of winter who was a member of
eternity he saved the paddle and we
would dicks my mother would line all of
us up and she'd beat the [ __ ] out of all
of us and you just be standing there in
line waiting for the [ __ ] beaten to
come right and then you'd always try to
block it with your hand and [ __ ]
smashing knuckles and then she'd send us
all the bed that was like her break
she'd do that once a day in like the
afternoon that was her afternoon break
she'd send us to bed and then we'd go
upstairs crying all sweaty and crying
and [ __ ] and sticky from whatever the
[ __ ] we just spilled that caused her to
kick the [ __ ] out of us and then you
know be up
ten minutes then we just fall asleep
that was it
hey what the [ __ ] I'm talking about all
right ask Bill promise you say Bill I'm
a senior in high school and have not
been to any of my school functions I've
been there sir
I've been there I didn't go to I went to
my senior prom I didn't go to the any of
the other ones I was a [ __ ] orange
haired freak in high school and I didn't
even have the courage to ask anybody out
I just saw what was in the mirror and I
was just like I'm not gonna do this to
somebody else what would I put this on
someone else I have never been to a
school dance and only a few football
games of my high school career dude did
I write this in a drunken stupor that
sounds like my high school career next
week is the prom for my school and I was
wondering if I should go I know people
say I should go and it would always be a
special moment in my life but will it
really is prom overrated dude you know
what you know this is a [ __ ]
depressed individual you know dude you
want to go and now you're gonna sit
there you were seen order this dude
you're too [ __ ] smart for your own
good are you gonna sit there and you're
gonna break down the prom how [ __ ]
stupid it is and the dumb songs and the
DJ and how you never you know it's
senior year you're never gonna see these
people again your life anyways should I
not go dude you should definitely go get
the balls up to ask somebody it's a
great exercise because someday you're
gonna see a girl that you're gonna want
to talk to and you want to have a couple
at-bats all right so just [ __ ] ask
someone to the prom go get dressed up
take the pictures have a good time
don't don't do what you're doing dude
you're overanalyzing life you're gonna
start pulling back from the herd and
you're gonna end up like me some psycho
babbling to himself and it takes you 20
years to get it right took me 20 years
before I met me and I finally got it
[ __ ] right and I'm starting to
function like a human being and thinking
about having kids and having a dog I'm
telling you man I'm telling you all
right it's it's a part of growing up
it's a social thing it's very important
I think it's very important to go to
your proms in your social events
because that's what life is about
there's a great documentary out there on
HBO called his way I am really bad with
names it's about this really successful
Hollywood producer and as I watched it
like I saw life lessons that I learned
only recently in life and I realized how
backwards I had life when I was a loner
because that's not what life is about
life is about networking hanging out
with other people laughing with other
people and becoming successful in life
is all about your ability to connect
with other people and so you got to
start as young as possible man you're
still young I would definitely do that
then you know and that's it man
I would definitely I would oh he asked
me some other did you ever go to a prom
and was it magical no it wasn't it
should have been but it wasn't because I
was a walled-off psycho and I apologize
to the woman that I went with I was just
like you I was sitting there when I read
the rest of us here I was thinking about
going but then came to the clusion
conclusion of going by myself would just
be oh I was thinking of going by myself
but then came to the conclusion that
going by myself would just be awkward
yeah do it you don't want to do that
you're gonna freak people out people are
gonna feel bad for you and then the mean
people are gonna tease you and it's just
gonna suck and then you're gonna want to
come back like Carrie and kill everybody
it's just it's a bad road she says so if
I don't go what should I do
dude go just go definitely go you want
to go I'm telling you if you didn't want
to go you wouldn't be asking me just
definitely go just ask somebody I know
there's some girls left asked sooner
rather than later and you know what dude
aim high who gives a [ __ ] if she says no
[ __ ] her she'd probably just end up
being some some fatty at a reunion one
day this is now when you want to go in
there just I'm telling you go there
psych yourself up aim high ask a girl
that you think is out of your league you
know take it to the prom make her
[ __ ] laugh and then see if you can
you know little something might happen
who gives it and if it doesn't who gives
a [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
someday when you see a dream girl sit
and Applebee's you'll have the balls to
go up to her because you [ __ ] talk to
that [ __ ] in high school
all right there's my advice all right
let's move on here number two friend is
going to be a dad trying to get him to
kill it Wow Wow
okay while we're already at an hour here
this is gonna be a long podcast a friend
is going to be a dad - trying to get him
to kill it oh jesus here we go bill my
friend's got himself into a shitty
situation recently gee I wonder what
this is
I'm really interested in to hear if you
have any advice for him and what you
have to say I got a call from him about
a month ago and said he was going to be
a father this is the last thing I
expected to hear he's 26 and pretty much
just started getting laid you [ __ ]
poor bastard see see this this is
another reason why you want to go to
your prom cuz you don't want to be this
guy the guy who first gets laid at
[ __ ] 26 doesn't know anything I'm
just [ __ ] dumps his load and the
first [ __ ] stupid waitress he finds
this is a very sad thing to happen to
one of your best friends it really is
what's sadder is the girl he knocked up
oh my god this is depressing me she's
not someone you'd want to mother your
child let alone be attached to for the
rest of your life she's a nice enough
girl but a little off
she admittedly has some issues in her
head and loves pills and weed a little
too much oh my god what did this kid do
let alone she is secretly married to
someone what dude are you sure you
didn't want to send this to Jerry
Springer I don't really know this story
but let's assume he is foreign and there
is no love involved Oh an arranged
marriage is that what you're saying
anyway when I got the call my friend you
spelt the word wrong I guess
respectively repetitively was at the
barn what word you're trying to say that
my friend was at the bar and yelling
about how he wants to kill it I take it
you're against abortion considering
you're saying kill it or you're just
trying to be
funny a day or so later when our buddies
get the news we all meet up with him to
have a convince your friend to have an
abortion dinner oh I see what do you
want one of your buddies we're down
there talking about how they might kill
all right so you guys gonna sit down
with him okay all right here we go
he now has given up and is going to have
it he said he tried talking to her a few
times about getting an abortion and she
won't have it she wants to have the kid
and every time he brings it up she hangs
up on him or won't answer his calls and
will avoid him for days so now in defeat
he's going to have the poor kid well you
know that's one of the things there it's
not the guy's choice which is funny when
they sit there and they say proach are
you pro-choice you know that that's not
for the guy
the woman decides unless you're really
smooth talker
I really think about having the kid will
make her feel some sort of self-worth
and that's why she wants to have it so
bad my friend is a sweetheart and I have
no doubt he'll be a good father but his
situation sucks we keep telling him that
he'll be attached to this girl forever
and he really needs to talk to her and
that we'll even talk to her and of
course a bunch of us pushing her down a
flight of stairs jokes followed God now
he is going with her to get an
ultrasound and stuff and won't even talk
to us about it I don't know how this
stuff works but she does but she's about
two months preggers and we think he has
a month left to get rid of the thing
what can he do and what can we as
friends do to help you know what guys
he's gonna have the [ __ ] thing I
would say I would say leave him alone
and just support him and tell him
whatever he does do not marry this woman
okay he [ __ ] up he got her pregnant
she wants to have it he doesn't have a
say in it and that's it it's going down
it's going down so you know he [ __ ] up
you know that's life
you know you [ __ ] you sometimes and you
[ __ ] up you don't get a do-over
which is basically what an abortion is
she's not going for the do-overs she's
like nope this is the game plan and
we're sticking with it just like the
Rangers even though people are breaking
their [ __ ] ankles they're gonna keep
trying to block shots all right that's
what she's doing she wants to have the
kid so now he just has to go with it and
this is what he has to do never move in
with her never marry her don't do
anything like that she's gonna be a
single mother he's gonna be a baby daddy
and what he needs to do now is he needs
to buy a [ __ ] lifetime supply of
condoms he needs to go out and find the
woman that he's supposed to knock up and
marry and in the meantime support that
kid that's what he has to do because he
busted a knot in her and she's keeping
it so he's [ __ ] he's [ __ ] when it
comes to that but his life is not over
he can stay he only has to deal with his
[ __ ] for 18 [ __ ] years he has to
deal with his kid for life I think what
he should do is the kid should be the
priority he should come to some sort of
Zen realization that he's not gonna
convince this woman not to be a [ __ ]
maniac if she is a psycho like you said
what I would do is I try to convince her
not to smoke weed or take any pills
during the [ __ ] pregnancy and and
that's it I mean his only other out is
if maybe she wants to put it up for
adoption but it doesn't seem like she
wants to do that but uh he just needs to
settle in to the fact that he's having a
[ __ ] kid but what you guys need to
make sure is that this woman does not
talk him into getting married and being
legally he all he has to do was plate
pay child support if he gets married to
her now you talk in alimony and all that
type of [ __ ] and then when he wants to
start his family with the [ __ ] woman
he wants to be with that's gonna be a
[ __ ] nightmare so that's it all right
so that's what I would do I would just
say listen just support him as a friend
and say dude if you ever [ __ ] bang
another girl without a condom
I am gonna I'm gonna disown you I'm
gonna disown you cuz it's killing me
watching you go through this [ __ ] so
just make sure you [ __ ] the abortion
he's not doing it they're having the
kids so now what you got to do is do not
marry this woman do not marry her and
and that's [ __ ] it that's it man
that's a brutal brutal brutal [ __ ]
situation they have but for the grace of
God anyways here we go let's read this
guy from London guy from London look at
this all the way across the [ __ ] pond
needs advice about girl with STD Jesus
Christ you guys have [ __ ] killing me
this week I'm a Londoner who just
discovered your stand-up uh cause I
gotta tell you you one of the best come
here thank you man that's [ __ ]
awesome you know great that is to hear
from another country you make me laugh
from the pit of my stomach which is a
pretty special gift to give someone so
thank you thank you
alright let's see if I can help you out
of your [ __ ] problem here anyway I'm
writing you because I just joined a
dating website I don't know how you feel
about online dating but my opinion is
always been that it's [ __ ] up who
needs to join a website to get laid who
isn't in some way a [ __ ] lunatic
right I think that's the way it was in
the beginning but now it's becoming this
phenomenal way of avoiding a cover
charge and having to buy somebody a
drink and just going right towards the
chick you want Nino what's going on my
girl just walked in [ __ ] brutal
questions this week you want to hear
that just the titles of these questions
or just one in general I guess it was
just this one friend is going to be a
dad trying to get him to kill it yeah no
I already answered it I just thought she
you know that that whole pro-choice
thing are you pro-choice the choice is
really the woman's you know if she wants
to vacuum it out like the Hoover's
getting turned on and what what a guy
makes a joke like that even though
you've never had a kid do you still feel
a little quivering in there no no you do
not
what other disgusting question you look
really good
you want you want to help me with this
one yeah okay so anyways uh so he always
thought the online dating things were
those online dating websites were just
filled with a bunch of psychos cuz who
can't just get laid but at this point I
think it's well I think there's an STD
attached to it let me read the rest of
this so I had avoided it being more than
capable of hooking up in real life but
my problem is that for about two years
now that's all I've been doing hooking
up dating meeting girls who never do
that thing to me oh nobody that he falls
in love with I feel like a husk a 31
year old I don't know if that means guys
from London I guess that means like the
old guy at the bar 31 year old and I'm
dead inside
oh I see he's dead inside because no
girl can make me feel how I used to in
the school playground with the first
crushes duh the thing that makes you
want to make pancakes in the morning for
or walk through the park or put on some
Lionel [ __ ] Richie all they want to
do is come home lately all I want to do
after I come lately is wash her off my
dick and bounce her out yeah yeah I've
been there which is no way to live
what Nia I banged a lot of broads before
I met you and that was the thing you
were like the second you did you jumped
up you said hang on a second let me get
let me you act like you were getting
something for her and you went in then
she figured it out when she heard the
sink was on too long that you had your
dick in the sink and you were washing it
up I say he's take the hand [ __ ] soap
and just [ __ ] act like I was jerking
off with soap and that's why I have the
clean [ __ ] I have today
all right plowing ahead the thing that
makes you want to Bucky which is no way
to live I'm actually a romantic guy I
cry at Disney movies out Jesus dude I
don't want to read this [ __ ] I fall I
want to fall in love again
it sounds like lyrics to a Lionel Richie
song it's 2011 people joined these sites
so I made a profile anyways this is a
[ __ ] long ass email okay so anyway
she's on this [ __ ] website anyway
after two weeks I'm probably thinking
about shutting down the profile
the only notable exception so far being
a divorcee who does yoga she invites me
to a bar we have a drink she complains
of being tipsy and needing to drive
I asked what she wants to do she corks
up the bottle and takes me back to her
place and literally takes a run at me it
was nuts to kind of seedy like she'd
watched some porn after this after the
split with her husband decided that that
was the way the world was now and
decided to emulate it for real so I'm
banging a mature granted pretty hot
mature woman who's looking at me with
this angry look on her face that porn
star [ __ ] thing that makes me feel
uneasy already while saying things like
do you like that huh that dick is nice
and warming my [ __ ] huh Jesus Christ
are you gonna are you gonna blow your
nuts right inside this [ __ ] yeah and
she's saying with the English accent too
that's [ __ ] hilarious and I'm just
feeling a bit sad and sign side as I nod
anyways this is the thing I meet this
girl 26 beautiful and I mean beautiful
she looks like a little elf or something
that just made it creepy an angel smokin
and she's smart funny kooky but in a
good hot way probably that dangerous
gonna break your heart way too but I'm a
sucker for that anyway we go for a walk
around the zoo not really giving a [ __ ]
about the animals because we're too into
each other like hey look an aardvark oh
you have really pretty hair it was great
I'm not that I'm not a bad person after
all my heart is beating again for this
girl I feel happy where's the STD thing
here alright so we leave the zoo go to
the bar for a kiss it's amazing
electricity then she goes I've got to
tell you something oh jeez here we go
here we go you gotta admit at that point
you were worried that she had a dick
right there's something I have to tell
you um I have three nipples and I'm
married to seven different men in Iraq
which is the sentence you don't want to
hear in a 1st April blah blah Sochi
anyways oh no I just looked ahead oh
Jesus brace yourself I look at her and I
say go on and she goes on to tell me
that a few months ago she was seeing
some guy who went down on her
and it turns out she had a Colt he had a
cold sore on his mouth and now she has
herpes ah so she's got an incurable STD
that can be passed on at any point what
do I do about that obviously I get the
hell out I should be running as far from
her [ __ ] as I can right but I like her
I haven't liked anyone like this for a
long time but I also never had a disease
I look at my [ __ ] in that look I look
after my [ __ ] in that way so I'm in a
dilemma I like her but she's damaged
she's she's a bit of a skank in the past
possibly but she did the right thing and
laid that on the table for me what
should I do
I'm clouded right now how much I'm
attracted to her I need your help bill
um yeah you get get the [ __ ] out get out
get out
yep you'll meet another girl dude you
don't need to do that listen she [ __ ]
up you didn't [ __ ] up no no no I'm
saying my [ __ ] you don't know how she
got the STD that's just a story she told
let me ask you a question she takes all
her meds she is on top of it and make
sure that you know she doesn't have any
breakouts if she does she does what she
needs to do and they use protection the
entire time and he goes to his doctor
and consults about listen my girlfriend
has this I don't want to catch it what
can we do or he finds someone with the
clean [ __ ] that makes his heart go
pitter-patter listen if you want to find
the right person in life you gotta be
selfish okay and I don't know anybody
who has on the list when they think of
this soulmate nobody has herpes
you're both clean in an ideal world you
don't have sores on your genitalia
but sometimes that [ __ ] happens and no
no this is what they need to do they
need to have a herpe social network and
people can just meet each other on the
herpes social network they don't have to
worry about it yeah and then they can
they can go halfsies on the herpes meds
and it's all good I'm preaching STD
segregation separate-but-equal social
website I think it should be tolerant
and I think you should talk to her about
it she probably knows everything that
she needs to do in terms of medication I
think you're full of [ __ ] I think if the
guy had sores on his dick
you'd be like you'd be like girl and you
start rolling your head like you were on
a talk show you need to get out that
[ __ ] really like the guy or girl then
you should just talk about it you know
what do they say like in Manhattan like
one in three people has an STD now
please don't quote me on that I could be
wrong but something insane were like
STDs are like through the roof so
obviously you should do everything in
your power to protect yourself but again
he's also just dating this girl he
doesn't have to sleep with her right
away then there's no [ __ ] point
there's no [ __ ] point as a guy let me
finish there's no point in being with
there's no point in being with the woman
unless you're gonna bang there's no
[ __ ] point
look I'm not if you actually if you feel
like this girl is the one then I mean
that's pretty powerful the fact that she
has herpes and you're still being like
you know but I've easy and he's been
careful he's been careful he kept his
breastplate on he [ __ ] at his this
condom on because how many people are
using condoms when they go down on the
guy and how many people are using dental
dams nobody alright goodnight connect
can I give someone night you're gonna be
doing that kind of stuff yes one needs
to be aware that that could happen all
right I'm gonna give some
one-night-stand advice
from a dirty filthy old man all right
one nightstand in seven years so what so
what it's all about it you don't have it
anymore you're done baby I got you it's
over all right wait a minute
this is what you do one of the first
things you want to do is you want a
romancer so you get out you get you get
out you're George Michael a cassette
tape no this is the thing okay
certain things don't change certain
things don't change okay one-night stand
you never ever ever repeat ever go down
on somebody you don't do anything okay I
don't even kiss him one-night stand
you go in you talk [ __ ] you pull the
[ __ ] hair you bend them over and you
put on a condom and you bang them that's
what it is what am I trying to [ __ ] be
a gentleman we're here to [ __ ] we are
[ __ ] you do it just the way
prostitutes dude that's why prostitutes
do you know that there's no [ __ ]
kissing anything did you want to bang me
put a condom on and you just do the act
you don't [ __ ] you don't try to sit
there and impress them you put on garden
gardener gloves your finger pop em a
little bit don't ever don't ever I'm
trying to help other guys don't ever go
down on a woman you don't know ever you
shouldn't do whatever and you should
wait until you guys are in a serious
relationship and then have her get
tested and make sure that that that land
mate finish that you're not going down
on a god damn sewer yeah the same thing
with the same thing women guys what guys
stick their dicks have him join frats
they had a [ __ ] ox at some point
there's some sort of farm animal
you never oral sex is for someone you
you're in love with I didn't give a [ __ ]
if you're [ __ ] into it you just you
don't do it okay so you can avoid
something like this so that's what I
would say listen if you think this
girl's the one then but I was just
trying to be funny that by all means I
guess you know do it but you're also
early early
you said it you already said it I don't
need to say it again people heard it
there's a rewind button um I'm an I'm an
I'm an hour well go grab and grab a mic
they're right there in the closet yeah
why don't when you walk in here just
come in with a mic and be prepared for
the gig
yeah don't ever go down on somebody in a
one-night stand I really need to make
that into a bumper sticker last question
if he really likes I said if you really
like sir then then definitely pursue it
but you know also do you want to deal
with this [ __ ] you know Scott understand
that you fall in and out of love with
somebody in a relationship and when
you're falling out of love with them
when you're really getting mad you're
gonna be thinking herpes [ __ ] you
[ __ ] cold sore [ __ ] [ __ ]
you get me thinking crazy [ __ ] I mean if
you're gonna pursue her whatever don't
be using that is in your back pocket to
throw in her face because like I said
anyone get an STD at any time it doesn't
mean you're a [ __ ] or you're a dirty guy
that does a bunch of stuff irresponsibly
sometimes [ __ ] happens it's life and
other times you're F yeah other times
Medicaid other times you're a filthy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
a man-whore or a female [ __ ] and what
you do is you gotta listen here when you
got an STD your [ __ ] damaged goods so
you got to come up with the [ __ ]
story I dis car one time told me she had
herpes she told me she had it on her
knee she said she was in a hot tub she
told me she told me she was in a hot tub
someone in there had it she scraped her
knee and she just got it on her knee and
as long as she didn't in this quadrants
of nerves and as long as she didn't
stress it wouldn't [ __ ] move and
gradually she starts telling me more of
the story and it magically moved up to
her [ __ ] vajayjay yeah she had
[ __ ] genital herpes and she didn't
[ __ ] tell me unfortunately I wore a
goddamn condom and the second she told
me the nice story I was like shoving off
to Buffalo shoving off to Buffalo you
know everybody if you're out there that
you know you you run into [ __ ] okay but
that's why you you always wear a [ __ ]
condom always always and yes and guy
there's a lot of guys out there who
can't [ __ ] maintain a [ __ ]
erection because they're so used to raw
doggin that if you put that on it feels
like they're wearing a winter coat all
right this is what you got to do don't
jerk off
for a few days and then try cuz then you
just be psyched anything is even and
remotely touching you down there well
rub one out with the condom just get
used to it
it sucks but I'm telling you this it's
gotta be nothing worse than [ __ ]
waking up and having that [ __ ] you know
she could also be lying how she got it
she could be like him she could have
been a [ __ ] [ __ ] going out banging
everything and that's how she got it and
you're right and people need to take
responsibility if you get herpes you
need to take like 50% of it you're a
hundred percent right but I'm just
saying
if someone was like oh I have herpes and
nobody you know wants to be with me even
though I'm trying I know you're right
I'm trying I'm trying to be funny I'm
not trying to be funny I'm sorry I give
this guy some good advice some good
advice you know you don't have to settle
in life but if you feel like this person
is the one then definitely pursue it but
don't be [ __ ] just sitting there you
know the worst way to go into a
relationship is if you feel bad for
somebody I feel bad I want to help them
it's [ __ ] pathetic you don't want to
do that [ __ ] you want someone who's your
equal or if not bet ain't [ __ ] high
suppose telling this kid he want to go
to a prom I go [ __ ] definitely go to
your prom and ask some girl that you
think's out of your league that's how
you improve your life you shoot her [ __ ]
up with you I have low self-esteem that
night and I was just like [ __ ] it oh no
I'm just joking we are an hour and 23
minutes into this podcast I haven't even
talked about the YouTube videos
I gotta go these are the best [ __ ]
YouTube videos that we've had in a while
fat kid reviews Thin Mints [ __ ]
hilarious guy throws bike to stop
thieves these guys these guys are
stealing like a Vespa and this this
[ __ ] Asian dude just takes his
bicycle and throws it at him it's it
[ __ ] it's Chuck Norris to the 10th
power
and then for those guys who love to
watch a baseball manager yell at an
umpire we have two wally backman videos
of him just absolutely losing his [ __ ]
one of them was hilarious like this guy
hits a foul ball on the other team and
they call it a home running this guy he
just comes out he's already cursing what
what the [ __ ] was honey that wasn't even
close
it wasn't even close and the umpire just
goes what are you talking about and he
just snapped what the [ __ ] what am I
talking about it's awesome
and then the last one is a comedian
who's drunk off his ass just talking
[ __ ]
Ryan Mervis check that one out we're
gonna put a couple of these videos up on
my Facebook page if you want no the rest
will be on the the mm podcast com if you
watch it on my Facebook page please
click the the share button so other
people see it they get exposed to my
comedy I appreciate that we have a new
donation button to the podcast if you
guys would like to donate any sort of
funds to the podcast I would greatly
greatly appreciate it cuz I have a web
guy now who I have to pay I have
overhead now it would be nice if you
guys could kick it some money there I
could give him a nice little [ __ ]
salary everything could get a little
nicer here yadda yadda yadda I'm also on
Twitter what is my Twitter name at Bill
burr is my Twitter name I wasn't sure
that's my handle I wasn't sure if that
was at Bill burr or at billboard.com but
it my Twitter name is at Bill burr and
that's it go Bruins they're gonna kick
the [ __ ] Habs ass tonight I'm not
being the tip you know what I didn't
even read I bet Dan Shaughnessy that
[ __ ] god of misery I bet now he's
writing about hockey that's the only
story he doesn't know [ __ ] about hockey
I bet if you didn't if he didn't give
him Lucic Chara or or [ __ ] Bobby Orr
I don't think he could name five Bruins
I don't think total Ray Bourque Cam
Neely you take all of them out that's it
that's the podcast for this week ladies
and gentlemen I hope you guys had a good
time if anybody has an STD out there
hope that wasn't too [ __ ] harsh I'm
not blaming you I'm not being a dick
okay yeah be honest about it don't be a
[ __ ] cuz that's how you got it because
someone else wasn't [ __ ] that's right
wrap it up wrap it up that's the podcast
for this week everybody go [ __ ]
yourselves on Phoenix
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]